[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen blog auf meinem kanal bei der dame
meine haare sind mal wieder komplett am
flieg ich gehe erst mal durch ihn dann
hoffe ich dass ich besser als der 14
jahre oder nicht besser aus also
freundlich im ton bisschen gel die haare
gemacht und ich gebe es auf dann könnt
euch meine fall das erste mal meine
haare gemacht habe was allerdings heute
auch das erste war das mein gott das war
ein beschissener über julia wird heute
zum aller ersten mal minecraft spielen
ich werde dann dem sitzen ich bin ja
schon wie alle bis profil in diesem
spiel jula das gab's noch nie wirklich
gespielt wir hatten letztes auf einem
kanal ich stehe gerade in meinem
bällebad das war die beste investition
oder zeiten wie eventuell wissen auf
einem kanal schon mal fortnight gespielt
zu machen erstmal doch nun ist der
moment gekommen dass jude zum aller
ersten mal das spiel ausprobiert mit dem
ich sagen soll auf youtube groß geworden
bin in dem ich angefangen habe meine
videos machen allerdings bevor das ganze
machen holen wir uns lecker brötchen hat
bringt nur wenige minuten später schon
gegessen freunde und kommen wir nun zu
der situation beziehungsweise der
situation das haben wir nun zudem warum
wir eigentlich dieses video
eingeschaltet hat juli spielt zuerst mal
minecraft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn erstes mal minecraft
bis er aufgeregt mit der maus kannst
dich ja cool oder laufe gut gelaufen
also juli läuft mit bas du siehst schon
genau du hilfst du schon gekommen
die ganzen sachen runtergefallen
guck mal was oben rechts steht juri
citys co
diese springt mit space genau das ist
die kuh die rechte die dem umbringen
das gut um die diesmal zu erklären das
spielprinzip ist nicht dass du die ganze
zeit für umbringt sondern das allererste
oder weil ich sag mal so was wenn du auf
einer einsamen insel werd was wäre das
allererste was du machen würdest
das ist tatsächlich ganz so blöd die
sache ist allerdings du willst ja dann
nicht in dem wald leben wenn es
irgendwie dunkel ist möchte ist ja
eigentlich ein haus hall oder du siehst
ja überall bäume möchtest du dir da mal
holz holen
was genau er ist wie bei fortschreiten
und bisschen länger
das holz wurde der baum ist noch nicht
komplett ab gefällt da würde ich noch
mal kurz hoch gucken genau da kannst du
noch ein bisschen holz holen
es ist nicht unrealistisch komplette
welt bei uns ist doch auch alles ecke
spiel entschieden
also ich würde erstmal noch ein zwei
bäume abfällen die da vorne irgendwo
herumstehen und du kannst ja auch immer
auf die tipps achten also oben rechts
steht jetzt beispielsweise auf inventory
prezi das drückt jetzt mal genau das ist
dein inventory das ist quasi so wie bei
deiner hose taschen da sind alle sachen
drin die du irgendwie einsammelt die du
mit dabei hat die cetera pp und
irgendwann ist ein elektriker auf eben
irgendwann ist ein inventory nämlich
auch voll
sie ist da sind nicht genügend plätze
für alle sachen die du einsame möchtest
warte mal ab bis es dunkel wird und die
monster kommen ich würde sagen ja das
ist der letzte baum ist die nab gefällt
hast einem tick war wieder auf geh in
dein inventar muss für jeden genau jetzt
kannst du nämlich mal auf das holz
draufklicken genau und jetzt muss man in
den strafen gegen rain und der ziehst du
schon recht wenn du aber drauf geht das
in auckland klenks also quasi nicht es
gibt nicht dieses normale holz hast du
fällst du dann baumstamm miteinander
sondern du kannst es weiterverarbeiten
zu holzlatten quasi und noch mal und
noch mal unter sich schon aus einem holz
wird immer also 4players genau da kann
es jetzt auch ganz häufig drauf rücken
genau du bist du fertig und jetzt hast
du 64 also ein komplettes takes place
jetzt nimmer diese clique mit
rechtsklick da drauf auf die auf plames
genau jetzt hast du geteilt jetzt kannst
du dir den tag legen genau jetzt hat es
noch mal mit rechts drauf ticken jetzt
kannst du noch mal ablegen genau und
nochmal mit rechtsweg an wird wieder
geteilt dann hat es wieder dahin legen
das ist klasse dass gar nichts dass
weniger platz im inventar
schöner rasen oder ja natürlich kannst
du schwimmen gehen
der durchfall er heißt hast du hier in
tintenfisch links oder gestürzt war halt
space gedrückter taste gedrückt halten
die durchhalten gedrückt halten sehr gut
juli ist eine kleine nahtoderfahrung
also juli entdeckt das spiel hier gerade
schon so ein bisschen dass ich gar nicht
hier ist hinten fisch gestorbenen hat
auch mal mitnehmen genau laufen
irgendwie ein bisschen nach hoch und
jetzt such dir doch mal ein ort wo du
dir ein haus bauen würdest am strand
warum das ist ja ein riesiger strand
jetzt juli
du siehst schon hier unten diese neuen
bereiche sage ich mal diese neuen
kästchen das sind items in die hand
nehmen kann
das heißt ich würde jetzt mal auf die
zwei oder du kannst mit dem mausrad
durchscrollen genau jetzt hast du den
kräftig termin da will ich jetzt einfach
mal rechts gedrückt da kann es nämlich
nicht nur blogger abbauen sondern auch
mit recht sehen kannst du platzieren
genau und jetzt machen wir rechtsweg
siehst du schon das ist quasi wieder
eine 4 links fällt im inventar nur halt
3 x 3 also damit kannst du größere
sachen sag ich mal brauchen bevor du
allerdings etwas baust jude würde ich
sagen gehst du mal mit dem mausrad
wieder auf die drei genau auf die auf
blanks und jetzt kannst du mit recht
sieht man ja mal um dich herum so ein
haus bauen
ich würde es wird rein nehmen ja fertig
oder ja gut darum das ist echt das
größte haus was ich jeden mannschaft
gesehen habe
also einige stunden sind vergangen da
hat sich hin ausgebaut
wir haben leider vergessen der tür
einzubauen deswegen zeigt uns mal von
innen zeit machen zwei sonder mtv cribs
room to wollen wir den leuten auch noch
mal von außen zeigen das ist gehen wir
zum zum strand im zeigt uns mal von oder
aus dem wasser vom strand genau das
sieht der bund damit du dich der
umgebung anpasst allerdings ohne spass
beiseite es jetzt wird's ernst ihr sie
schon es wird dunkel
scheiße das ist auch keine brille auf ja
wir brauchen kohle für fackeln also
kohle kriegst du normalerweise aushöhlen
nur ein höhen warten halb monster und
dafür braucht es auch ein schwert und um
kohle allgemeinen abzubauen
brauchst eine spitzhacke des linken das
waren zombie ich würde sagen du solltest
mal zurück in dein haus gehen genau da
kannst du noch rund tag gehen wir zu der
seite genau auf der suche nach einem
haus rein zu kommen jetzt
normalerweise hat man dann im bett und
können schlafen aber wir haben kein geld
haben wir gerade die helligkeit ein
bisschen hoch gemacht damit juli ein
bisschen was sehen kann
das kann auch selbst ja ja manchmal sehr
gut dass auch lassen wo doch nicht
spannend mit dir minecraft juli kommen
wir machen ein bisschen action gehen wir
hier immer die axt machen wir jetzt den
weg hier vorne frei genau wird ja genau
macht das mal weg immer nach draußen und
jetzt schauen wir mal ob wir hier nicht
irgendwen finden der vielleicht mit dir
und interagieren will etwas pace
gedrückt genau damit sie nicht wieder
untergeht wir schwimmen uns anderen
seite das hier ist zuckerrohr lka bambus
glaube ich in minecraft damit kannst du
dir nachher genau strohhalme da sind
zombie juli
da konnte man die lage sehr gut jude
sehr gut und noch mal und beim nein
julia schneider du musst die ganze zeit
drücken genau wie bei sportlern ganz
schnell schnell hat er bringt dich um
das sogar drei herzen dort doch regel
auf danach hinunter solaranlage stellen
was seinen albert laufen
ja das ist bei gegen ein unfair gewesen
oder also leute ich bringe mal eben kurz
wieder nach da hinten zu ihren sachen
dass sie nicht komplett alles auf mein
gott jupiter steht vor dem haus was wir
da ja du kannst immer streichelt ist
böse der ist doch ganz liegt der hund
ist tot
jeder hund stammt vom wolf ab
an der stelle würde ich allerdings sagen
dass wir minecraft wiesen spielst du
jetzt noch mal du hast gar keine chance
in diesem spiel wenn ihr wollt dass
juden und ich eventuell mal zusammen
minecraft spielen also ich auf meinem
account und jule mit ihrem account dann
und dann machen wir uns eventuell mal
der welt oder so dann lasst mal leichter
freunde allerdings fahren wir jetzt
erstmal tatsächlich wieder zurück an die
nordsee weil es sich in köln viel zu
heiß ist und wir uns dachten okay wir
fallen zurück nach köln ist das spiel
deswegen haben wir das problem dass wir
beiden allerdings ja gerade haben ist
die fähre geht um 16.30 und kate ihr
euch an den letzten block erinnern wo
wir die fähre schon mal verpasst haben
16 38 ist die ankunftszeit gerade text
wir packen das
es wäre auch langweilig einfach
pünktlich zu kommen gutzeit zu haben
noch einen kaffee zu trinken
vielleicht wurde gleich geht es zum
letzten mal hier war sie mein koffer wir
haben tatsächlich mal wieder die fähre
verpasst glücklich kann es tatsächlich
nicht so meine stärke
mit diesem ding leute kriegen wir jetzt
darüber
die kleine maschine die ich hier gesehen
habe wie meldet
schon freunde gefunden also wir haben
und herren wir sind zurück in der
nordsee angekommen sarah ist auch da auf
jeden fall ganz kurze info warum sind
wir diesmal nicht mit der fähre
rübergefahren sondern mal wieder
geflogen weil ihr pünktlichkeit nicht so
in die wiege gelegt bekommen haben
ich blogge nächste scheißegal was sie
anzieht also wir sind eigentlich zeit da
los gefahren doch dann eine riesige
masse ja wir sind ein bisschen später
schon mal aufgefallen trotz der riesigen
massenkarambolage in krefeld ja richtig
gelaufen war
ja sind wir denn dahin kommen dass wir
in köln wenn ich nicht ausgehalten
der plan ist dass wir jetzt erstmal nähe
gehen wir doch das essen können wir was
mitbringen
vielleicht stehen wir ja gar nicht was
es um mich geht es erst mal eine
kleinigkeit was kommt nein denn nach
riga wem diese tüte zu dass es gibt es
nicht klar er packt mich ja gerade erst
mal unsere sachen aus werden dann etwas
essen gehen und dann sind wir auf einer
party eingeladen
und da werde ich dann noch eine
kleinigkeit film habe der größte teil
des videos ist ja schon geschehen
juli spiel zum ersten mal minecraft ist
er da hat es mir erst mal meinen
kräftespiel juli hat dir gefallen
ehrlich ich weiß aber echt scheiße die
leute aber schreibt wirklich machen denn
die kommentare auf ihr wollt dass wir
eventuell zusammen
boxen minecraft spiel
jule und ich wir gehen es starb
[Musik]